I think that whatever you say honey you
want a head massage that's the only
thing that depends on the context
exactly
it can be a little bit like oh you know
like oh I have to do it again I just you
know you you it depends on the content
where the good women are gone
if you're with the right woman that you
that won't happen if you're with the
right Roman if you're with the right man
that won't happen
it depends on the context she's right it
does but it doesn't matter I can't I
have to be honest I think women that say
this because I hear this a lot it
typically means I am disagreeable and I
don't want to listen come on okay
typically and or the men I pick aren't
worthy or like something like I like
bombs basically is the other one like
it's like well some some women pick men
who are I think for their character to
mask I don't want to say that because
then you're going to be like feminine no
like two you know like she feminine
enough the man is really masculine she's
in her feminine
in time but sometimes she's like see I
see the language in her feminine yeah I
knew you're gonna pick that up
I just think it's like nonsense like
it's just it's like these women that go
on Instagram and they'll say oh I'm a
feminate I don't know if it's you I hope
that's not what you do but but like it's
like I'm now a femininity coach and
there's some genuine ones I'm not gonna
say there's not there are genuine ones
that do this too masculine feminine
energy
the ones that I see that are full of
because Men actually look to solve
problems so if you look at like men's
Improvement it's very practical so it's
very much like go to the gym
screw a bunch of girls so you know how
to or do you know I can't even ex-corn
star that's been on my show he has very
practical you know tips on not my thing
right but like and or they'll do
um like go to the gym make more money
women it's very like broad like like
soft life I'm gonna sit at home
um and it's never like concrete steps
I've only had one like femininity coach
give me like real concrete steps that
isn't just like journaling or
say about uh feminine feminine feminine
coaches
um they operate from
um
again energy but like what is to be
feminine they tell you be creative like
focus on things that make you tap into
the womb like that traditional woman
that's what they are all about like try
to for I've I've been in touch with some
of them they tell you like listen to
music dance or create something uh with
uh like a painting or something uh
tangible with like artistic yeah um and
to me this sounds like nothing useful to
a guy I don't listen to you like go
listen to some music but I can but like
I'm just I just said yeah there's only
been one femininity coach that like
actually talked about real stuff and she
helped me write most of these like words
to add in the short term it might seem
that it's not helping but imagine on the
long term rather than a woman being in
her as I say masculine energy which is
like shouting and confronting she learns
to be submissive but like step by step
first of all by tapping into these
skills then to to be comfortable just
doing uh even something such as cooking
they tell you cooking makes you tap into
your feminine energy more and more so
maybe by building those little habits uh
I think cooking yeah guys I don't think
cooking is bad but
I just
why we need these now we I agree with
you I agree that it shouldn't matter but
we need this now because a lot of women
and men as well forgot that Natural
State you know what's your natural state
as a woman I don't know because I get
really confused because I hear these
like women talk about soft life right
but like our great-grandmothers really
didn't have a soft life they were milky
like at least out in the U.S they're
milking cows like have you seen Amish
people that's where they used to live
like they do not have a soft life and
soft life to me is living off a man
that's what I see as a soft lie maybe
yeah when you ask where all the women
good women went I mean to me they went
to confusion and Independence and this
confusion is is a diffused awareness
because the Primal nature right A man is
hunting he's directive in his Focus
and a woman is diffused because she only
has a certain amount of daylight hours
to get as many berries as she can and
she's very skilled at it she can do it
way quicker than a man apparently and as
part of our survival mechanism and so it
is kind of obtuse and Broad when we
think about how we go back into our
feminine nature so we're not you know in
this CEO role of our families of our
relationships of our businesses and then
we got to come home and then deal with
the reality of like you know being a
partner which is a totally different
energy it's not you're not directive
yeah you got to get the meal on the
table and my grandmother my mother they
worked really hard as Homemakers it was
like taboo for them to work yeah but my
generation and our generation now it's
very it's a lot of confusion and we're
still growing into that you know how do
we balance that just Beyonce's full
I'm being serious she made a Triple
Single Ladies all of these things with a
ring on her finger
I think we're very capable you know what
I'm saying there's a lot of confusion
about being from the night to be honest
you'll say you're right from the 90s
2000s whatever there's been there's been
a lot of Independence Independence do
your thing blah blah blah blah blah cool
you can do your Independence but if you
don't need a man
someone said modern day Gathering has
turned into shopping
but why do you think women are having
burnout endocrine disruption cancer
depression I mean there's all these
issues with women's health because
they're trying to be um
like a hormone doctor about this he said
like high strike women and men don't
handle stress the same and it really
messes up our hormones being like high
stress positions and you know what the
matter said if you stay in your feminine
energy and you come home and you look
after your partner your man is going to
want to look after and do everything in
his power to make sure you're good yeah
that's as simple as I can explain it
like as long as you stay in your family
and you look after that man he's going
to do everything for you regardless
naturally but earlier with what I was
saying if you're not showing certain
things to him he's going to see that all
right cool yeah she's not really mankind
I'll sit back I'm there but I'll sit
back a little bit but if he sees you're
making effort like like even cooking
cooking if you want when I get through
to a man's heart is through his belly
100 as simple as that you get what I'm
saying yeah and I also I fell into the
boss babe culture for a long time when I
was obese and I and then I started
losing weight but I was still in the
boss baby culture I was like oh I don't
need a man like I'm fine and it was when
I had the daddy issues when I was I
didn't have a good relationship with my
father and it wasn't until I hit my
relationship with my father that I was
like oh okay I actually you know it's
really important that I I don't have to
work like a man I was so stressed I was
so anxious all the time and then I just
let it go it's like I don't need to do
that my future husband will provide for
me my future husband will do these and
I'll fall into my feminine roles I will
cook I will clean I will take care of
the kids I'll take care of the house
like that and I'll be I'll go I'll
Garden what did you do did you quit your
job no I just okay I was just curious
well I guess I did a couple of miracle I
just I flipped two houses last year and
I was like I don't want to do this
anymore so I just decided to stop doing
it that's cool it was a miracle though
really yeah
no because that I was the boss right I
had to be ever the provider I had to be
everything and you didn't have that
example and I think that's another part
of where all the good women have gone
inside of this Independence inside of
this confusion it's fatherless families
and like Pearl was saying earlier if you
don't have the example how are you
supposed to know and you haven't had the
example Penelope so it's a miracle
purely purely yeah no it is and it was
it was like growing up with you as my
mom like you played both roles the dad
and the mom and so that was very
interesting because I grew up thinking
oh I I don't need men like men are
terrible and I even thought my father
was terrible because now he's like my
best friend but I think we're we're the
good women are going is they think that
it's a bad thing to be feminine I think
that that the mindset of women today
feel like
um and now if you're feminine and
traditional online people are like
you're you know you're not a feminist
you hate women you are terrible you are
a disgracious society you should go die
and it's like wait wait what like women
are the most beautiful things on planet
they create human
so why are women putting putting on well
I think
if women want women to fail and see that
I think I think it's because we're not
supposed to be competing with our moms
generation because the thing is like if
you have a 45 year old and you have like
a 25 year old girl it's like you a lot
of times the guys you might want are the
same age because women like 45 tend to
want guys like it's like five to seven
years younger where women
um 25 want guys five to seven years
older this crossover and I think bitter
older women that don't want you to win
will tell you the wrong information
that's true and and it's because like if
they're if they're being a hoe right
like what's the worst feeling when you
take a test and you fail what's the
worst feeling when everyone else
succeeded yeah right but if you turn
around and they say I failed too it's
like you feel a little bit better so
it's like these women want other people
to be miserable in their negative
decisions
of people because of it because of
succeeding in in my relationship and
having a healthy relationship with my
father people dislike me because of that
and it's like why do you hate me for
having a healthy relationship with my
family am I am I so would you would you
say and especially
this is like technically just a woman's
problem then because it's women that
it's not technically men that put down
women you know it's women that put down
women the woman trying to be men hurt
are hurting the the feminine not not the
feminine the beta men right they're that
that's hurting beta man that's why we
have betamen it's because of the
masculine well I think it becomes a
problem because you have 80 percent of
women screw in 20 of men so then women
don't respect the average guy I did a
show the other day and like most women
said they wouldn't date a bus driver
they're above a bus for our average
checks and it's why you have average
chicks saying they're at the level of a
celebrity no offense but like it's like
you have average chicks thinking they're
they're so great when it's like
literally you are average you're average
looking even average mindset most people
are average and men will accept this but
women won't it's like an insult for us
to be normal so then you you won't see
normal women dating normal men but do
you feel like that that is because
social media has a lot to play for they
feel like there's a lot more I think
it's social I think it's social media
and dating apps they feel like they've
got more accessibility to hire people I
mean they do like because the issue
nowadays because this is what made me
think about this I'm like how would you
find a good woman and I was thinking
about this and I made a chart and I had
like the body count of a woman on one
hand and I had the looks of a woman on a
one hand and so I was like a woman
that's eight to ten with a high or a low
body count good luck keeping her do you
know what the list is gonna be for a
girl that that's like that hot with like
like the competition is crazy and so
it's like you could be dating a woman
and if there's High competition for her
Drake could slide in your girl's DM 100
or maybe it's not Drake it's the town
whoever right and then I was thinking
about it and I was like unless a guy
sleeps with a lot of women how is he
going to know the difference between a
woman that's been out with everybody and
a girl that does it has it they never
did they can't no they can't know unless
they've been with a lot of girls and I'm
like it's kind of unfortunate because
it's like the only solution for the men
seems to be to sleep around which I
don't think is you know great for
society but it's like it's women's fault
because we're the ones doing the
sleeping do you think that men should
have more than one woman
um I I think that it's silly to date
certain men and expect monogamy so I
think it's silly to date say Jason
Derulo Chris Brown These are extreme
examples but there's certain men that
it's very silly to expect it because
he's never been monogamous and they
never will be I think monogamy in
general is better for a society I forget
to sit the higher I'm even talking on
average men no more men on a day today
because obviously you said earlier on
that there's more women under Earth than
men yeah so on average how we are
naturally
do you think that the average man should
have one woman
um I think that it's better for society
if monogamy is better because you get
like a growing
um having a lot of sex sexless men like
usually causes slight Society to
collapse
um so I think monogamy's better by and
large but I think that a certain
percentage of men are always going to be
non-monogamous
um and that's kind of the way it's been
the last like two million years because
85 it's like the last
I don't want to say the how long it's
been like this because I don't remember
off the top of my head but I know like
historically they always it seems like
all of society has been non-monogamous
because 17 men reproduce for every uh
one 17 women reproduced for every one
man like 8 000 years ago and on top of
that there's like two women have always
reproduced for every one man but it's
actually um or 40 of men have never
reproduced forty percent of men I'm
sorry I'm butchering this but but the 85
percent of um like 85 percent of society
has generally been monogamous for the
top 15 percent of men have just been
like slaying is it yeah well well okay
great you do a lot of stats here yeah I
know a lot of average men out here
that's probably not on these stats doing
the same thing and and when I say a lot
I'm joking if you're just talking
average men in London obviously London I
don't know about America average and
what in sleeping with a lot of women no
like average looks average money would
you average looks average average job I
couldn't even give you examples of a few
average men that are big in weight and
just got normal jobs that aren't dealing
with a lot of women across the board
um well there's a couple things so I
mean typically again like there's been
studies on dating apps and in in person
where women find 80 of men is ugly not
okay not average they think ugly he is
unattractive ugly would you say the top
the same on these dating apps
um yeah maybe yeah I don't know I don't
I don't believe so um
I think that I think that if you look at
the numbers social media is the number
one my way people are meeting 100 so
social media and dating apps and like
when you look at so then the question is
if that's where people are meeting what
do the numbers look like in the dating
apps well women only swipe right five
percent of the time so that means on the
number one way people are meeting we're
sharing men
because there's always going to be free
men because we're the hunters so we wait
100 wait say that again it's always
going to be men because we're the
hunters we're always going we're going
to be the higher anyway do you know what
I'm saying yeah but when you're saying
the average men that get women they
probably get women over the age of 30.
because women tend to go for looks and
so in their 20s I fully agree with yeah
you know I agree with that because I
feel like we're single mothers you're
100 between 20 and 30 women are very
selective in what they do and then when
they get to the 30s you started reading
off a lot of stats about pregnancy Dairy
actually yeah when they start realizing
that and they go for the average they
feel like they can come back to that
agreement or even go back to man that
they was that was trying to get them
when they were 18 19 and feel like they
can go back to them but obviously with
men it's a bit different because men
yeah at 30 we start peaking we get
correct yeah so we start it's cheap
there's a change you get what I'm saying
yeah yeah and so that's why I say women
pick non-monogamy in their 20s when they
have the most leverage yeah and they
pick the 20 of men that in their 30s
they we tend to pick
um like the rest basically and so the
issue is like when when women cheat who
do they typically cheat with you guys
know anyone
correct so the issue that a lot of these
guys are getting into and this is why
guys don't like typically like a lot of
guys will say I don't date women over 30
and it's not a looks thing it's that if
she's 30 like how many relationships has
she had is one of those guys better than
me and does she want to be with him and
the odds are he probably is because in
her 20s she had more leverage in her 30s
so what are the odds in her 30s she can
get a better rather than in her 20s
likely right and he was probably top 20
alone slightly when they have that
relationship from 20 to 30 there's
there's always that one guy that can
always come back in the background as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible